PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED.
>> VERY ENCOURAGING NUMBERS.
THANK YOU.
>>> U.S. SURGEON GENERAL DR.
VIVEK MURTHY JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING.
I WANT TO ASK THAT GIVEN HOW
RARE THE BLOOD CLOTS ARE, SIX
CASES OUT OF SOME SEVEN MILLION
DOSES ADMINISTERED SO FAR, AND
THE POSSIBILITY THAT THIS COULD
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE VACCINE
HESITANCY.
IS THERE A RISK THAT THIS PAUSE
IS AN OVERREACTION?
>> GOOD MORNING.
IT'S GOOD TO BE WITH YOU TODAY.
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THESE CASES
ARE RARE AT THIS MOMENT SIX
CASES OUT OF OVER SEVEN MILLION
DOSES ADMINISTERED.
WHAT'S VERY IMPORTANT IS SAFETY.
AND INSTILLING TRUST IN THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT THE
SYSTEM IS WORKING FOR THEM.
THAT WE'RE GOING VIGILANT.
AND EVEN THOUGH THIS WASN'T AN
EASY DECISION, IT WAS A RIGHT
DECISION TO PUT A PAUSE ON
ADMINISTRATION OF THE VACCINE
AND TO GIVE US A CHANCE TO DO
TWO THINGS.
ONE IS INVESTIGATE WHETHER THERE
IS, IN FACT, A LINK, BETWEEN THE
VACCINE AND THE SIX CASES OF
DANGEROUS BLOOD CLOTS.
SECOND, TO GIVE US A CHANCE TO
TALK TO THE MEDICAL COMMUNITIES
AND TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE ARE LOOKING FOR AND TO ALSO
HELP UNDERSTAND HOW TO TREAT
THIS -- THESE BLOOD CLOTS IF
THEY DO ARISE.
>> WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO PEOPLE
WHO PLAY FEEL AFTER THIS NEWS
EVEN MORE HESITANT TO GET A
VACCINE?
>> WELL, HERE'S WHAT I WOULD SAY
-- REMEMBER THAT FIRST OF ALL
THESE ARE RARE EVENTS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SIX OUT OF
OVER SEVEN MILLION DOSES OF THE
VACCINE ADMINISTERED.
SECOND, AND REMEMBER THIS, AS
WELL, IF YOU RECEIVED THE
JOHNSON & JOHNSON VACCINE OR IF
A FAMILY MEMBER OF YOURS
RECEIVED A VACCINE, YOUR
LIKELIHOOD OF DEVELOPING BLOOD
CLOTS OR ESPECIALLY THESE
DANGEROUS BLOOD CLOTS IS
EXTREMELY RARE.
YOU WILL LIKELY BE OKAY.
JUST LIKE THE MILLIONS OF OTHERS
OF PEOPLE WHO WILL HAVE HAD THE
VACCINE.
AND FINALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT
MESSAGE TO SEND TO EVERYONE IS
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ONE OF
THE THREE VACCINES OFFERED HERE
IN THE U.S.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE,
OVER 110 MILLION, HAVE RECEIVED
THE PFIZER AND MODERNA VACCINES,
AND WE SEE FEEL C-- WE STILL FEL
CONFIDENT.
I BELIEVE WE'RE ON TRACK IN
VACCINATING THE COUNTRY.
I THINK WE WILL FIND OUT WITHIN
DAYS WHAT THE ANALYSIS IS OF
THIS PAUSE.
AND THEN WE WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE FORWARD WITH OUR
VACCINATION CAMPAIGN.
>> DR. MURTHY, SOMETHING KEEPS
POPPING UP ON YOUR SCREEN.
WE WANT THE VIEWERS TO KNOW WE
SEE IT, TOO.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL IT
IS.
THERE'S A DOG OR SOMETHING
POPPING UP AROUND YOU.
ALL IS GOOD --
>> IT'S MY LITTLE BOY --
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO SORRY.
AT LEAST WE CAN EXPLAIN -- THANK
YOU, THANK YOU.
>> THAT'S AWESOME.
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TO YOUR SON.
GOOD MORNING.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO ANTHONY'S
QUESTION FOR A SECOND.
IF THIS IS RARE AND IF YOU STILL
FEEL THAT IT'S SAFE, WHY HAVE
THE PAUSE?
ALL THIS DOES IS GIVE PEOPLE WHO
WERE HESITANT TO TAKE THE
VACCINE ANYWAY -- SEE, I TOLD
YOU THEY RUSHED IT, IT'S NOT
SAFE.
ALL THE EXPERTS SAYING DON'T
WORRY, IT'S ALL GOOD.
THIS IS STILL VERY, VERY
FRIGHTENING.
I KNOW YOU'VE ANSWERED THIS
QUESTION.
BUT PEOPLE ARE STILL EXTREMELY
NERVOUS.
WHY PAUSE IT IF YOU STILL THINK
IT'S SAFE?
>> GAYLE, TWO REASONS TO PAUSE.
ONE IS, AGAIN, TO HAVE A CHANCE
TO DO THE ACTUAL INVESTIGATION,
TO SEE IF THERE'S A REAL LINK.
THE SECOND IS TO THAT HAVE THAT
TIME TO COMMUNICATE WITH
PEOPLE -- WITH HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ABOUT WHAT TO LOOK
FOR, BUT ALSO HOW TO TREAT THE
CONDITION.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT THESE
BLOOD CLOTS IS THEY'RE NOT THE
AVERAGE RUN OF THE MILL BLOOD
COT THAT WE HEAR ABOUT ALL THE
TIME.
THSE ARE AN UNUSUAL TYPE OF
CLOT THAT OCCURS WHEN YOUR
LEVELS OF PLATELETS OR CELLS
THAT HELP WITH CLOTTING IN THE
BLOOD ARE ACTUALLY LOW, AS WELL.
AND IN THAT SITUATION, YOU DON'T
TREAT WITH THE USUAL BLOOD
THINNERS LIKE HEPARIN, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT YOU TYPICALLY GIVE
IN THE HOSPITAL.
THAT REQUIRES ACTUALLY A VERY
DIFFERENT TREATMENT, AND THE
FACT THAT YOU GIVE THE
CONVENTIONAL TREATMENT EVEN
WORSE IN THIS SITUATION.
THIS IS WHY WE WANTED TO
COMMUNICATE OPENLY WITH PEOPLE.
BUT REMEMBER THIS -- THESE
PAUSES ARE ACTUALLY COMMON WITH
NEW VACCINES AND DRUGS ARE
ROLLED OUT.
THIS IS NOT UNUSUAL.
WE'RE JUST DOING THE DUE
DILIGENCE TO MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING IS SAFE SO WE CAN
CONTINUE WITH OUR VACCINATION
EFFORTS.
>> OKAY.
WE NEED TO BE REMINDED OF THAT.
KUDOS TO YOU.
NEVER EVEN MISSING A BEAT WITH A
SON WHO CLEARLY LOVES YOU.
CLIMBING ALL OVER YOU.
>> VERY SMOOTH.
>> DR. MURTHY, WHAT'S YOUR SON'S
NAME?
>> FAGIS.
HE'S 4 YEARS OLD.
AND WE'RE VERY CLOSE.
>> HE LOVES HIS DAD CLEARLY.
>> THANKS TO YOU BOTH FOR